there was a time where
UPN went on this crazy run crazy A crazy
one yeah you look at girlfriends when
you look at Martin when you look at
Monique UPN had about four had about
four successful strong shows yeah four
successful strong shows at the time I'm
not aware what the ratings were but this
was a network that was about the
opportunity
um or opportunities for people of color
I feel like there was a moment this is
Young me I'm not I'm not in any place of
success or future success I'm a young
stand-up but in this time it seemed that
the the black
TV star male or female we were given but
by the way at that time was also Morris
Chestnut Gabrielle doing all those
movies that was all that was a that was
a time that was a time it was right at
the beginning of 2000. there was a time
and I don't I don't know I don't know I
don't know the correct way to really uh
really say it but it's like sometimes I
don't know if we if we talk about that
time and the things that came in that
time enough because it's like we want
that again and we want to see that but
the thing is that wasn't the first time
of that so there was another Renaissance
that was the Living Single moment there
was there were shows happening then
because that was right before that and
part of what's happened in television
that there have been fits and starts so
we come in waves right and what I think
is happening now that I do think
blackish was at the beginning of
ushering in
and with streaming there's like a
genuine
shift in the tide that I hope stays okay
because I think we have established and
one of the things that happens in
with any black business is that we're
always a surprise you know I'm sure
you've heard it absolutely you know so
it's like we're always a surprise and
there's never data to follow it up to
show that this is not a surprise it's
not a flu no this is this is this is not
a fluke this is like the audience is
there and the talent is this it's proven
this is it's actually but it's always a
fluke because there's no data to support
it so I'm hoping now between insecure
Atlanta blackish I mean we could go
there's so many shows and all different
kinds of black people so that we don't
all have to be represented by one show
like that might not be you get to choose
that's not for me that one's for me I
like that one I don't really like that I
like that one but I don't like that one
like that was one of the things I so
love about black lady sketch show
because we get to see black women like
when
why is that the first opportunity for
that what yeah we we've been funny
forever yeah come on so why is that just
happening and to be able to see them
explore and do all those different
things is so exciting I hope we don't
for we don't forget our power there's a
lot of powerful women of color now that
are part of the creative conversations
that are that are that are important
absolutely that are that are doing to
work to make sure that we are we're seen
in the positive light and in a true life
well in a true life and I think that's
what it is is that we we don't have to
um be
uh narrowed in or I don't even know what
the word is to what other people's idea
of us is you know and you know I think
black woman of the backbone of society
so as you should what do you mean you
know I mean heart to heart with heart
okay and then
who that yes and who there you go
[Music]
back
this is a problem this is a problem
[Music]
foreign